Одеса, на мій погляд, з міст-мільйонників, які розташовані у прифронтовій зоні,
залишається найбільш мирним та спокійним містом.
Життя повертається в якусь довоєнну нормальність, якщо можна так, звісно, говорити за таких умов. Як це вдається?
Я можу сказати, що лише завдяки нашим Збройним силам та тій героїчній обороні ЗСУ та підрозділам тероборони,
які стримують сьогодні тиск окупантів на рубежі Миколаєва, Вознесенська.
Фактично, одеський фронт сьогодні там.
Тільки завдяки стримуванню наступальних дій супротивника вони не рухаються у бік Одеси. Це перше.
Друге: що стосується морської операції, то також завдяки нашим Збройним силам та удару по крейсеру "Москва", який затонув,
сьогодні ми говоримо про спокійнішу ситуацію на морі, про те, що чекати наступу чи висадки десанту з боку моря -
це може статися, але ймовірність набагато нижча.
Без прикриття крейсера "Москва" все морське угруповання військ противника, окупанта
сьогодні суттєво зменшилося.
Що стосується можливого нападу з боку Придністров'я, також за оцінками ЗСУ, за оцінками експертів,
говоримо про те, що сил і коштів там не достатньо для розвитку самостійної наступальної операції.
Якщо все це діятиме як єдиний фронт наступу - тобто Миколаїв, Вознесенськ, з моря та Придністров'я,
то це ще якось можна розглядати.
Але самостійна операція та розвиток наступальних дій з боку Придністров'я - сьогодні це малоймовірно.
Чи готується місто, військові, з якими Ви набагато більше, ніж ми, спілкуєтеся,
до того, що ракетні удари стануть інтенсивнішими і що місто чекає доля якщо не Маріуполя, то Харкова, який сидить під "Градами".
Ви знаєте, я, може, ще місяць-два тому, може, більше взагалі вважав би, що це фантастика.
А щодо двох місяців, більше двох місяців війни, я вже багато чого не можу пояснити сам собі.
Наприклад, навіщо треба варварськи руйнувати Харків.
Навіщо потрібно спальний район у Харкові просто знищити взагалі? Навіщо це? Яка мета?
Як це може виправдати будь-яка спецоперація з денацифікації та демілітаризації?
До чого тут денацифікація та демілітаризація до руйнування цілого житлового кварталу прекрасного міста Харків?
Я не знаю, що в них у голові. І чи є в них взагалі щось, думки якісь...
Мені здається, вони наробили цих ракет - і у них є план, вистрілити, припустимо, 20 ракет в день.
Ось вони шпуляють їх, вибачте за таке слово, посилають ці ракети за якимись своїми планами, не знаю, чи є у них ці плани...
Нищать українську інфраструктуру, руйнують міста.
Тому я не можу виключити, що завтра їм не вдарить щось у голову
і вони не почнуть бомбардувати або обстрілювати ракетами місто Одесу.
Складно передбачити те, що сьогодні твориться.
Говорячи про прапори з іншого боку, пам'ятні дати та масові заходи,
Ви багато років ходили у перших лавах 9 травня.
В Одесі традиційно широко відзначають це свято.
Торік навіть, незважаючи на ковід, було велике святкування.
Що буде цього року, на Вашу думку?
Ну, по-перше, я вам скажу, я ніколи не намагався дотримуватися якоїсь політичної кон'юнктури:
сьогодні це одне, завтра - інше.
Я з повагою ставився, ставлюся і ставитимуся до історії Другої світової війни
та вкладу Одеси - міста-героя - у перемогу над нацизмом та фашизмом.
Тому я особисто абсолютно свідомо, як ви сказали, у перших лавах іду дев'ятого травня
і покладаю квіти тим захисникам Одеси, тим, хто обороняли її та хто її звільняв.
І вдячний їм за те, що вони визволили Одесу, весь світ від нацизму та фашизму.
Цього року ситуація досить складна.
З одного боку, хотілося б все-таки, щоб ми традиційно поклали квіти,
щоб ми традиційно віддали данину пам'яті тим, хто гідний цього.
З іншого боку, ми не впевнені в тому, що саме цього дня, як і в інші дні, як ось 2 травня,
ті, хто сьогодні частково і тимчасово окупував українську територію, напав на нашу країну,
не захоче відзначити по-своєму цей день.
У них уже, розумієте… Насправді жахлива річ.
23 числа в ніч перед Великоднем було завдано удару і загинули 8 людей, у тому числі 3-місячна дівчинка.
Це православне свято. Вони ж кажуть, що Росія - православна країна.
Проте це не завадило 23 квітня цинічно завдати ракетного удару по житловому будинку,
2 травня завдати ракетного удару.
Тому ми відповідальні за безпеку, я, зокрема, за безпеку мешканців нашого міста.
Тож складно сказати. Сьогодні ми в роздумах, думаємо, як нам віддати шану
і в той же час убезпечити одеситів від можливих і провокацій,
і завдання різних ударів артилерійських, ракетних, авіаударів.
Для когось війна злилася в один довгий день, для когось вона складається з дат.
Для вас ракетні удари 23 квітня і 2 травня змінили уявлення про цю війну?
Ви знаєте, взагалі дуже складно для людей старшого покоління, для людей, народжених в СРСР,
а це набагато більша аудиторія, дуже складно сприймати те, що зараз відбувається.
І те, що коли я говорю деякі речі, я говорю їх усвідомлено, але коли я говорю -
я собі не міг уявити, що я колись у житті скажу ці речі.
Що сьогодні Російська Федерація - країна-агресор,
що сьогодні вони вбивають наших людей,
що сьогодні вони повністю втратили людське обличчя,
що сьогодні напередодні 9 травня я не можу поставити знак рівності між російським та радянським солдатом.
Тому що радянський солдат визволяв Європу,
радянський солдат боровся з фашизмом та нацизмом.
А сьогодні російський солдат, російський офіцер стріляє в моє місто, вбиває моїх земляків, не маючи на те причин.
Так само, як чинила 1941 року гітлерівська Німеччина.
Ще вчора я не міг уявити, що таке можливо, а сьогодні це факти.
Країною котиться певна хвиля не декомунізації, а перейменувань багатьох топонімів, пов'язаних з російської культурою.
У Києві, приміром, готуються перейменувати станцію Льва Толстого, вулицю Пушкінську.
В Одесі цих топонімів дуже багато.
Одеса була пов'язана з російською культурою багато років.
Я пам'ятаю, як проходила тут перша хвиля декомунізації, досить конфліктно у 2015 році.
Чи готуються одесити до нової хвилі?
І чи взагалі залишиться в Одесі місце для російської культури після цієї війни?
Це дуже складне питання для всіх нас.
Сьогодні Російська Федерація та її лідер припустилися, на мою думку, колосальну помилку щодо і своєї культури,
і свого народу, і взагалі свого місця на колишньому пострадянському просторі.
Буквально поруч із мерією ви бачили трофейну гармату з фрегата "Тигр", який колись стріляв по Одесі.
Там на одній з табличок було написано: "Слава російській зброї та захисникам Одеси". Її ніхто не чіпав.
Одесити славили зброю, яка захистила наш будинок.
Це не була слава російській людині…
Ми змінюємо ці таблички, прибираємо їх, адже сьогодні це звучить дуже різко, абсурдно.
Абсурдно виглядає, коли російські стріляють у нас ракетами, а ми пишемо: "Слава російській зброї".
Але все це зробив Володимир Путін.
Адже сьогодні все, що стосується російського…
Знаєте, вже підсвідомо ловиш себе на думці, що навіть підсвідомо інакше сприймаєш і тих талановитих людей:
і талановитих акторів, і талановитих представників культури різних напрямків із Росії, які сьогодні мовчать.
Начебто освічені, начебто культурні люди і не дурні, і грамотні. То чого ви мовчите?
Ви що, не бачите, що тут війна? Ви не знаєте?
Вони кажуть, що в Росії за сто кілометрів від Москви чи двісті там уже телевізорів немає,
вони, мовляв, ще не знають, що відбувається. Їм сказали, вони всі повірили, побігли…
Але зачекайте хвилинку, а інші люди, які сьогодні мають можливості,
які мають родичів за кордоном, у Німеччині велика діаспора, у США - вони цього не знають?
А яку ви реакцію хочете тут, якщо ви заохочуєте все це?
З вашої мовчазної згоди це все відбувається.
У період війни, жорстокої війні сьогодні, звісно, деякі рішення можуть прийматися досить емоційно.
Тож хотілося б, щоб цього не було.
Приміром, біля мерії також стоїть пам'ятник Пушкіну.
Але найцікавіше, що цей пам'ятник було споруджено на зібрані одеситами гроші. Одесити колись зібрали гроші.
Пушкін бував у Одесі, і це наша історія.
Звичайно, якщо буде ухвалено рішення про такі процеси, це буде достатньо не те щоб болісно,
але фактично ми почнемо нову якусь сторінку історії, абсолютно нову.
Говорячи про сторінки історії, ми з Вами востаннє бачилися у Києві в суді.
Проти Вас були висунуті досить суворі звинувачення, у тому числі в розкраданні міського бюджету, розкраданні міської землі.
Що зараз із цими кримінальними справами та судами? Про це всі забули, але, певно, не ви?
Та ні, чому? Не лише я - НАБУ теж не забуває.
Ви знаєте, я вам скажу, коли мене запитав один із журналістів, каже, що ось зараз є можливість,
що хто бере участь, активно протистоїть агресії, що можуть бути якось закриті справи і таке інше.
А я відповів і вам сьогодні відповім. Я в жодному разі не хочу, щоб моя справа була закрита з якихось пом'якшуючих обставин.
Я хочу і вимагаю, щоб суд відбувся і я отримав виправдувальний вирок. А я у цьому впевнений на 100%.
Я був упевнений, коли це сталося в 2018 році - перша підозра, як і в інших.
Тому готовий відповідати на ці запитання.
І в мене надії сьогодні більше з'явилося, що, можливо, суд буде вже не таким політизованим,
і ці лови неугодних політиків і такі політичні справи все-таки закінчаться.
Не для того я сьогодні працюю, щоб мені хтось вибачив якісь надумані претензії чи, як їм здається, мої злочини.
Я працював тут, працюю, живу тут, і мені ніхто сьогодні не відповів на жодне моє запитання.
Наприклад, яку статтю закону України я порушив? Який закон порушив?
Яку статтю регламенту міської ради я порушив?
Яку статтю статуту міста Одеси я порушив, приймаючи рішення, чи міська рада, приймаючи ці рішення.
А все інше - це... Знову ж таки, хочу, щоб це був виправдувальний вирок.
Я ніколи не звертатимуся для того, щоб сказати: "Ну, ми ж всі воювали, ми всі воюємо.
І, можливо, мені зараз треба якось вибачити щось за мою сумлінну роботу, наприклад?".
Не хочу і не звертатимуся. І навіть якщо буде запропоновано таке, я наполягатиму на тому,
щоб продовжилося розслідування, і в суді була встановлена правда.
Велике спасибі.
Дякую.